how's it going guys matt here for
codetech tutorials we're going to be
doing a little decorator a demo just
kind of a custom secondary one
to maybe go after the first episode if
you just want an example of well i guess
it's just going to be me making a
decorator out of some kind of interface
so i'm going to make decorator 2 folder
here in the project and add to our cmake
under design patterns just to add
subdirectory of decorator 2 so we get
that project added in then we'll go to
it
and we're going to copy in one of these
cmake lists
change it to decor deco 2 i suppose and
delete all this extra stuff we still do
want to main but we'll see what else we
end up with here of course the main is
going to be the main entry point as
expected but we want to work up a little
example so what i was thinking here is
well we make an interface for something
that you might use in a game because
that would be a pretty common use case
if you're using c plus plus for making a
game
and uh there are a lot of things we
could do
here i thought about we could for
example decorate up a character or a
monster or a just an item and there's a
lot of stuff like that so maybe we'll
work with item so what we want to do
here is basically give the item an
interface and then from there we'll add
some kind of components you can add to
it and we'll decorate those up
as needed and as you'll see this will
make the item very extendable in the
future because you start out with the
base interface interface class and then
you can make decorators as needed
depending on how you want to expand the
item all right so let's go ahead and
make a new file and we'll just call this
uh
just item.h i think is fine for now and
we'll include it in our main because we
are going to use it at some point so for
sake of visibility we're just gonna
display stuff in the console so we're
mostly going to be using strings where
as in a lot of examples you might have
more than just strings or a lot of real
life examples such as you might have a
company meshes and stuff like that that
could change too so keep that in mind
for gaming type stuff
all right well let's dig in so we want
an item first of all this is a header so
let's put our pragma once up here and
let's make an interface for an item so
let's stick with uh structs for now
let's make it a class
and we'll call this
suppose just base
item and we want to make sure this is
pure virtual so to do that let's make
first of all a virtual destructor don't
forget the squiggly
and then we just want this to equal
default and then we want some kind of
your virtual function here to uh
kind of say what it actually is
or
you know to make sure it's an interface
so maybe we want like a get
i like having get name here
and we'll just have it return a string
that way you can just get the name of
the item set this equal to zero
make sure it's an interface
and of course we'll have more stuff as
we go uh depending on how we build this
up so we probably want a few basic
things now there's a lot of thought that
can go into this we could put damage on
it we could put little special
statistics and stuff like that so we
need to basically decide
the root cases of what an item is in
this particular game for example
and i want to keep it simple it's going
to be very easy to expand deeply quickly
so let's talk briefly about what you'd
normally do if you weren't using the
decorator what you would do is you would
basically just extend this endlessly for
every option you have so
say for example we have a weapon
it would implement from base item now
let's just not call this base item let's
just call this item but implement
item
of course we'd have to implement the
pure virtuals which we can do here on
visual studio except it just gives you
the option but doesn't actually work
thanks visual studio you mind fixing
that would be great if you would
so we do need to implement this get name
so what we do is the same thing uh
virtual
string
get name
and we'd return the name so we could
have that uh private i guess it'd be
better to make it protected in this case
if every item has a name
it would be something like that since
everyone's everyone's got one it's fine
here we can just get rid of private
we're not really going to use that yet
so uh there we go we have a weapon it
implements what it needs to but it's not
really a weapon because it hasn't
changed enough stuff yet we would say
something like the weapon needs more
than that
like it would need some some damage oh
and this should be override
and this should also probably be const
const because get name is just together
it doesn't change anything and this
string could also be const but yeah
whatever we'll just leave it how it is i
think i'm spelling virtual wrong
there we go now there's no way to
actually set the name either that's kind
of a problem here so when we make this
implementation we need to make it so you
can set the name
like so
and actually we could just do that even
in a more cascaded fashion
by putting that in this root one
like so so that automatically gets
implemented into any of these classes
that implemented and we no longer
need this exactly but we still need to
forward this somewhere um so
we would have to do it something like
this that way we can forward it along
to the item constructor and that's the
only way to change the name
but it's not a weapon if it doesn't at
least do some damage right so let's get
that in here and just we'll just make it
an integer protected integer
so this would actually be the weapon
decorator well this would be a weapon
okay we haven't got the decoration this
is this is how you would normally do it
without the decorator what we're doing
here
so we just need to add in damage to this
constructor as an integer we'll just
call it d
and we'll set damage to that
and just like that we can now
instantiate a weapon and give it a name
and some damage we probably want a
method to get the damage and if you're
working with all public then you don't
have to worry about all these getters
but just kind of trying to stand
follow the best practices here this one
doesn't need override of current course
we could make this virtual just so other
people can override it and there we go
we can now instantiate a weapon so
that's the normal way of doing
inheritance right now we could go
uh weapon uh and i'll call it something
we'll just call it weapon one and we're
offered three constructors here as you
can see were
offered a copy constructor a move
constructor
and the one we
implemented ourselves we need to know
about string here too otherwise it's
that's why i said error type and that
won't pop up let's include string since
we're using it we could use const care
stars but then we'd have to worry about
managing memory the string will just do
that for us so we might as well take
advantage of the features we have we're
going to use the one we implemented now
if you don't want the other if you don't
want the move once to be allowed you can
just delete them
so you can go something like this
that equals delete and then the same
with the move one which looks like this
so if you delete those now when we go
back to our main and we go to build this
you'll see that those options aren't
even there anymore so
uh that's just a c plus plus thing but
now let's go ahead and give this a name
we'll say a uh i don't know call it
a basic sword i guess and we want some
damage i don't know how about three and
that's what it'll be
standard c out
we'll just go weapon one dot get name
space here
and damage
and then we go weapon one dot get damage
now you'll see you'll notice that it
didn't have much help for this get
damaged new line there
but we do have it implemented here and
it's not pure virtual so it should work
just fine let's go ahead and give this a
run
so
yeah and you can imagine oh i spelled
virtual wrong that's all it is
built string wrong just a few little
errors
alcohol just item there we go okay fixed
all those errors now we should be able
to run this let's look for
deco 2 that's what we named it
we might as well put it in release
let everything recompile here
and hit play
so cmake was kind of automatically done
in the background oh we have a
error with string here
oh
an error with cl we just need i o stream
here we're going to use cl so let's go
ahead and try that again and we get our
basic sword damage of three so that's
generally how you would implement uh
stuff without the decorator and you can
expand as needed you if you want another
special type of weapon you would go
class
uh i don't know whatever it is
maybe you would implement types this way
like you would have a sword weapon an
axe weapon and all kinds of stuff like
that and it could just go on and on but
this would implement or inherit from
weapon
so i'll make a quick example of what
that might look like so we'd have all
these functions already but we want to
make a new constructor for magic weapon
and add some new properties against
magic damage
and
make a constructor here and we want to
do the same thing
give it a name
default damage
and uh magic damage pull that one md and
we do this basically the same thing we
just for this one to the weapon
constructor with n and d
which will then forward it down this
line and take care of that and then
we'll have our own magic damage which we
need to construct to this md and that
would be it that would be the whole
implementation but of course now the get
damage is different because it's going
to add the magic damage so this we would
want to override
something like that
so we'd override the get damage if it's
a magic damage to if magic weapon to
include the damage plus the magic damage
and now we've extended it further and we
can implement that one as well
i'm just going to copy these lines down
call this magic weapon
all this weapon to all this magic sword
it needs one more thing here
say it does two magic damage there and
we call the same function and let's give
this a run so we should see a new item
here and we see the damage it does is
just three with the magic sword now why
is that it's because we haven't changed
this to the new weapon we're calling yet
damage off the first one we created so
of course this three so let's update
that coding correctly helps and there we
go we see the magic sword does five
damage as intended so the as you go
you could do this
and this pattern just goes on and on you
may get another class for your next
special type of weapon and so on and
eventually you end up with just a
massive hierarchy of tons of different
things so this is where you might decide
alright this is getting like crazy i
have so many different classes for every
little specific thing this is when you
introduce the decorator if you see this
sort of thing happening so you'll be
able to save a lot of lines of code if
you uh
basically just have a few of these and
then just make what you would call
extensions and i will go ahead and show
you how to do that in a dynamic way and
with these extensions the great thing
about them is on the fly you can add
remove change them and stuff like that
so in this certain in this case of a
game it might be great for if you're
enchanting or repairing weapons and they
i guess it'd be more for like enchanting
or adding properties and maybe you can
remove properties and put different
properties on you know standard kind of
enchanting stuff on like skyrim or some
rpg or something this initial setup it
works great for kind of static weapons
but
we'd have to add functions to change
things which we could do but it might be
better if we just have you know the root
item and then we have it set up how we
want as in decorated how we want all
right so let's
let's change this code well we have some
options for how we want to do this and
keep in mind that there are drawbacks to
doing this as there are with any of
these things so you know like the
advantage of this whole weapon and an
extending weapon of magic weapon is you
could have a weapon slot and you could
put a magic weapon in it if you're using
pointers uh once we go to this other
pattern it becomes a little different so
keep that in mind so i think the first
thing we want to do here is uh well this
is actually okay item and then we have a
weapon i find that to be okay but what
we want to do further on rather than
extending weapon in this magic weapon is
extend item once again here
and this is where we would add some
properties instead of adding the whole
magic damage thing here what we would do
is
instead have a pointer to a weapon so we
want to pass a weapon into here to magic
up essentially so what we would do here
is go
um this should be just an
item
this is where it gets up a little weird
because this is a pure interface right
we're everything from it but since
weapon is an item we could pass in
weapon or we could pass in anything so
it might actually make more sense just
to call this magic and then work with it
from there so now what we have to do
here is basically make special
constructors for magic and have them
work off of
any of these decorators like this is
basically an item decorator this weapon
here so this magic we want to take item
pointer here but how do we know which
one it is and this is where you might
need to do some planning because well
you could say you've got to give it an
item but you can't give it this default
item because this one is not allowed to
be constructed it's pure virtual so it's
got to be something that implements it
we got another thing in here for the
magic damage because this is this is
magic well let's just call this one item
here so what we would say here
is we now construct
an item but the item has no default
constructor we need to decide well which
one are we actually working with so in
my case i'm going to keep it pretty
simple here i'm going to make this
second one just a mod because this is
essentially a magic item
what type of magic item depends on what
item they ended up passing
into here but essentially we'll say
our item well let's uh let's give this
one a different name
item underscore
item underscore is going to be our item
that we passed in
and then uh we want to give it
the mod so what is this mod um it would
be basically our magic modifier let's
just place that as an hint and call that
magic modifier
so it really depends on our design
really but essentially we want to set
the magic modifier to this mod but you
know we're designing a magic system
essentially and this is very bare bones
but we got to give it some item to be
magical and what the mod would be is
basically what i'm thinking here so then
we just pass in that mod so what we want
to do here with this magic decorator i'm
considering putting the decorator
keywords on these i don't know though
but uh it doesn't necessarily matter a
whole lot it's more important that the
uh you wouldn't normally do that if your
coding is the point you normally just
kind of do the thing you're doing and
you don't necessarily call it a
decorator it just it's what it's known
as
in the programming world okay so we have
this magic
right and inherits from item just like
this one we've got an item pointer
protected here we don't have that weapon
obviously because a weapon can fill out
an item and a uh
yeah so that's this would be like the
concrete class i guess we call it
concrete
weapon i guess that would be yeah by
concrete they just mean it's an actual
instantiation so
i guess we'll name it that just to kind
of uh simplify a bit there we go
and so now when we make an a concrete
weapon you pass the string and the
damage and that's it but if you want to
make a magic
weapon you got to put the item in there
and you need to basically modify it with
this magic we got the magic modifier
there and now
if we want to override git damage so
it'd be like uh virtual and get damaged
well we can't override get damage
actually doesn't really make sense uh we
just need our own
get damage and this yeah it doesn't
necessarily need to be virtual so
and get damage
const and we want to return
well
we can't necessarily tell that the item
has damage damage is a weapon property
right so that's where it gets a little
tricky here that's where you need to
decide whether you want to do the
casting or not to get the proper values
out of this also it doesn't like this
constructor this magic constructor
because if you hover over it it'll see
say
item has no default constructor so this
item doesn't just work
so easy with no default constructor so
we'd have to put one
in here is uh what we'd have to do
so well we have the name you know the
name is kind of something we want on
every item but
we could do this differently so i could
make it a little more simplified
make it unnamed so to speak so we could
just go item and just have it this equal
default
eight bolt
and then this should be happy thing is
it's just not going to get a name so
maybe we want a void set name that gets
instantiated
but
do we want to mess with that do we want
to mess with giving people the ability
to change the name
that's something you have to decide for
any of these and i think it's fine so we
might as well put it in here
and we should probably make this a
let's just make it copy
gonna be inefficient but at least we
know who's owning the data there on that
set name and it's us we copy a new one
that we own of the name
which might be inefficient for what
you're doing because if you only ever
set this name once maybe a move
operation would be better but we're not
going to get into that for now that's
more of an optimization all right so now
this is happy
but it doesn't set name so we have to
call something like item dot set name
and we'd have to give it whatever name
we want so we have to pass that in here
somewhere basically so we don't have a
name right now
so we just go through that now we are
going to have an idea of our in our own
program which of these concrete classes
we have and which of them can have this
magic applied to them because we might
also have let's say for example on crete
armor so we're going to stick with a
dynamic way of doing this and instead of
damage it's going to be damage resist
just keep it simple
and we'll call this one dr
vr and just like that we have
a weapon and we have a concrete armor so
the point is you can have as many
concrete as ones as you want since
they're all items we can apply this
magic to any of them and this modifier
to any of them by just using this here
this magic
decorator what we would call this one
and we would want all this magic
decorators operations to go off this
item and we could this is how
you know things get a little interesting
here this is where we need some helper
classes to do some casting checks and
see what we have so we know we have
armor and we have weapons we know that
those are valid types so we probably
want to make an add-on here just like a
like a private function that operates
specifically in this magic decorator we
could make it even a lambda we could go
auto uh
let's think about this here for a second
we want to if we want to detect what
type it is well we got to design that so
i go in the think tank a little bit here
for a moment to think about the best way
to do this but uh basically
it probably be with something like an
enum that has all the different types
listed
ultimately or something like that to
accompany your concrete types because
essentially what you want to do is have
it be able to check which one it is and
return that
and then just have a little switch
statement that maybe figures that out
just some accompanying framework so i
guess we'll just type it up real quick
um
we'll just have an item type and we'll
have an unknown if it's not set
we can have armor we can have weapon and
that's all we have right now
now this is just a declaration of the
this enum type here it doesn't really do
a whole lot else other than that and we
need the function to go with it so we
could go something like just declare a
function
that returns item type
and that's let's just call it uh what is
item type
and what do we pass in here we pass in
an item pointer and this is where we
want to do the
the cast check so we do a switch on the
item
[Music]
or well not a switch
which would be inappropriate for this
actually
we would do a cast check so we would go
like auto
uh
armor trying to think of a great name
for it so you know what it is ask to
armor equals dynamic cast to an armorer
or concrete armor pointer then we pass
it this item
so if this succeeds this succeeds we
know that the cast is correct i think we
actually need a pointer here there we go
if
the cast armor is successful
then
we want to return
item type armor
i think that'll work
and then we
you know so we don't go any further if
it's it's armor so we also want to have
a weapon here call this one the cast
weapon and you could kind of define this
structure as needed and then
if it gets to the very end we will just
return
item type
unknown now let's see if this actually
works i
this is kind of weird to instantiate an
enum like this i don't know if it's
actually gonna see it as a proper item
so we'll see we are on c plus plus 17 i
believe i don't i think we haven't
actually specified so it's probably
given us 14 i think that's the default
here even though we have this
see
okay if our c make version is greater
than 3.12 we try c plus plus standard 20
so i guess that's where they started
supporting it or something uh that's in
just all our little c mix here for all
these little properties actually we
forgot to rename these targets and all
of them so i guess that's something i'll
fix while i'm here
we did it in factory and then i just
never changed it
but it doesn't cause any errors because
it's not that uh i'll change that one
but we'll just go through and do this
real quick
make this fix for these and then we'll
get back to our work here in decorator 2
and save all close all of these
all right well now if we go back to our
main this no longer works we don't have
weapon anymore it's now concrete weapon
and magic weapon so let's go
let's try our new example concrete
weapon
takes a name takes a damage
and then we want to make a magic uh
concrete weapon so we give the magic
type let's call it magic weapon one and
this one needs
something to identify with
a pointer well since we didn't declare
it as a pointer here we got to put the
reference in front in front of it and
what did we spell wrong about magic
let's have a look magic decorator
and it also wants the magic modifier in
there as well let's say it's a two for
like plus two now magic
decorator is an abstract class here
that's uh part of the problem so we
definitely need
to implement this get name method
like so
and this should now return
a proper name so we could put armor or
something like that on the name because
this could have yeah i guess we just say
what it is that's probably going to be
the easiest way to do it and this is
where something like using our
helper function here what is item type
will help out a lot so we can go
[Music]
something like well let's use a switch
statement and we can use it on item type
we need
item type though so let's actually
declare one in this function auto uh
well we can't do it as auto let's go
item type this item type
and we'll set that equal to whatever
this returns so we'll use that function
equals
and then we pass in the item pointer
that we've set which is right here
so we uh basically this will handle the
casting and return the right type it'll
set that and then we can switch on this
item type and do a maybe a c out in the
different cases or something like that
so this gets a bit ugly but you kind of
get the point uh i wish there was a way
to
quick fill these cases out because it's
just
the same thing over and over item type
farmer item type unknown so there are
different ways to work this out we could
have like a part of a string being
filled out by the switch statement and
then have the standard c out at the end
or the return at the end rather so it
probably makes sense to make this some
sort of string builder here
which you could abstract out further if
you want but basically we want to return
whatever it is
in this case so you know the other way
i'm kind of thinking of doing this that
would be good is if you have an
elaborate name
you might want your string being built
as you go through these get name
functions
is the the point so
just to say that there are options
i know you guys don't always like
options you're just like tell me how to
do it don't give me options but
the reality is options are good even if
they are confusing at times so
essentially this just does a quick
little string converter type thing and
there we go
return unknown on the default 2 which
shouldn't happen but we want to future
proof it a little bit if we add to the
type and forget to update this uh
maybe we'd even make this unhandled and
since this uh well yeah
we abstracted a lot of the code there
we could even abstract this further and
have it return the string
like so
or we could make an override of this
where it's the exact same function
but instead we return a string we could
use either
and just have it
directly return these that would save us
some lines of code so yeah let's just do
that
so you can't overload by return type
yeah so i guess in some way or another
we'd have to change this a little bit
what is item type let's make this one
say string what is item type string this
one will just be what does item type so
uh yeah you could choose one of the
other and not do both of these you know
in reality but
if we're gonna do this sort of thing we
might as well
make it more simple
just do this
and there we go that cleans this up a
lot you know and you can imagine that
this sort of function is more of a
utility it might be used in a lot of
different places in the code that's why
it might be a good idea to
separate it out
rather than have it right here
in the in the function as chances are
we're going to use this get name
somewhere else too so that's how we do
the casting and figure out what type it
is with this magic decorator and that's
how we could go even further with it um
this item class doesn't have a get
damage but we have to get damage and
these weapons so that's something that's
another thing we have to think about now
do we put the damage in the item or do
we have these
stay separate as they are so we don't
actually want these to be overwritten i
don't think but it gets uh it gets a
little weird here because
well we probably want another front end
here like on this magic decorator
something like ant uh git magic mod well
this could obviously just return the
magic modifier
so
and that would just handle it so we
could abstract it further wherever we're
using the code but anyway and we could
say if it's a
you know we could do a little string
comparison on this return which is slow
it's going to be better to do enum
comparison rather than string comparison
so that's kind of why it's best to have
both of these but if you're uh wanting
to print line or get the string
so for some reason for your interface
that's when you want this one
if you're doing comparisons it'd be
better to use this other one so that's
that's the thing so git name assumes you
want the string and uh and that's kind
of
kind of it but in this magic mod
we might want something else we might
want to kind of think here what this
what would be best here you basically
want to be able to call functions from
the armor
and the weapon and that's not
necessarily super obvious how to do that
here because i'm sure we have a pointer
to it but we need to get the casting to
see what it is so that's basically what
we'd have to work in so this example
might seem a little con convoluted at
this point and it to be fair it kind of
is now what you probably want to do from
here is like really think about how
you're actually planning on using this
in this example it's just like a
whatever example so i don't necessarily
have a plan on how i'm going to be using
it which sort of makes it difficult to
design because typically you think about
okay what do i want what do i need for
my game or interface or whatever i'm
doing and that's what you design in this
case i'm just kind of like showing you
random examples but you can see where
you would go for here but you want to
get to the next uh you want to get to
the next thing so look at this uh let's
look at this example and think about how
we could do this all right so we've
decorated up a weapon
gave it some magic and we can call on
weapon one any of those base functions
we can call on magic weapon only the
stuff from magic decorator which of
course we still have the get name so
that'll work um and it should be a
little different so if we call get name
here we should get a blank because it's
uh blank
but if we call get name here we should
get its type so we should get we should
probably call this function something
new like get name or get type
and we're getting back into that uh get
uh item type
as string
so get item type string might be more
appropriate and then we could just have
the actual get name
uh let's do that virtual habit return
item name well we'd have to like build
this up
let's just do a string here
called item get name
we're going to be doing a lot of copying
here very inefficient but plus equals
space plus
item
get
item type string well you wouldn't need
to call this an item you just call this
excel it handles all that automatically
and then you would have this name string
to return so we're calling the root one
here
that'll get whatever we set the name is
as
uh maybe i don't know maybe we want this
bracket thing say whether it's armor
like to the right of it or something
like that okay so let's give this a
little try so we know on weapon it's
probably going to display blank we
actually need to call set name here why
is this thing complaining all of a
sudden oh we need to override it name
here const
there we go now it's happy
so on this original one yeah we need to
we need to say something about it here
we need to set the name basically
we don't well i guess we do it right
here yeah let's just see what happens
here get damage should be
a magic weapon now this doesn't work
right that function isn't there so
instead we have to get
like the magic mod
and we have to add that
the weapon that's in it now this this is
where you would need to check casting
and design careful functions because you
would be like get damage
plus okay
so we add those together the damage and
the magic mod so you would have this
somewhere deep in your your game logic
and as you can see we now need to track
two objects but here's the thing and
here's where like flyweights come in you
could use this same weapon all the time
especially if it is const
like like so but then this doesn't allow
cons so you got to think about that i
guess maybe you don't want to be
constant all right let's give this a run
we should get the first name and damage
basic sword damage then we got basic
sword
unknown it shouldn't be unknown
we're getting unknown from this kid name
oh we're saying
it item type string
it should
pass
one of these and work so let's put a
breakpoint here and uh put some debug
give it a run
and we'll see it gets here attempts to
cast the armor which should be wrong so
this should be null still no okay but it
is a weapon so this should not be null
but for some reason it seems to be oh
i'm trying to cast it to armor again
whoopsie so a little error in the code
there no wonder all right so let's stop
this and rebuild it and we'll go again
i'm gonna take this breakpoint out it
should work fine and there we go
and we have a basic sword that now says
weapon you know we should put magic on
there if it's magic
right here on this get name
see we build will build up the string we
should start it with
equals
magic
and we'll see we can uh can really work
this up this name to be as specific as
we want
there will be a magic the get name and
then well look at how we want to do this
let's start it out with the name and
then on the second part that's where
let's put all this together
it'll be a magic well i guess we can
combine these now like so
it'll be a magic and then the item type
that's the name string
so let's give that a run see how that
looks
magic weapon cool
and we could even we could go further
here we could put the magic mod on there
he'd get this magic modifier
as a string and put it on there so we
probably want it after magic's like
magic plus one armor or something that's
uh that's how i see it anyway
so let's do that
right here our string builder
uh let's go
to string i think is the function put in
here magic modifier
it's standard yeah okay
that should work
so let's check that out now we need
another space in here somewhere put a
space right there
and we also need like a plus or a minus
now these can be minus that's the thing
so
we need to decide here uh
let's
we could do an inline thing to put a
plus or a minus um let's go let's do
that on a new line just for simplicity's
sake
so we'd want to switch on let's see if
magic
modifier if it's less than
one well it's less than zero we'll say
and we put a minus
well we return a minus
so let's put a little minus symbol like
that otherwise we are going to return a
plus symbol so this kind of brings up
the point of what if you pass in zero as
the mod it's is it still magical is it
gonna get plus or minus we could
very quickly wrap this in another quick
if say if magic
modifier not equal to zero so that way
it's definitely plus or minus it's not
zero and it'll just entirely skip this
entirely not put any symbol if it's zero
so that solves that little uh
graphical glitch that could come up
there we go we got basic sword we got
magic and uh the thing is when you make
a magic sword you probably want to
rename it something else so you would
call
magic weapon one
uh set name
yeah set
name and give it a new name
of like uh i don't know armageddon
plus two sword
oh i'm doing this entirely wrong i'm
doing gotta pass it into the function
we're not writing a function arm
all right so we let's go ahead and do
this so it's based off that basic sword
what the set name didn't happen let's
check this magic weapons get name well
it causes the basic items get named but
it should be different at that point
shouldn't it right that's what you might
think
well let's walk through and see what
this is doing so we're going to put a
break point there let's run this
alright so so far our weapon is still
named basic sword we're going to call
set name on this magic weapon
and let's see what it goes into it goes
into the set name from the base item
and operates on the base item
so we'll now see that this basic weapon
is still named basic sword but this one
that it copied in because
if we look at this decorator
just takes a pointer
and then it does this operation so the
question is what is this doing and the
answer seems to be that it's making a
copy of the weapon
by some means here if we look at magic
weapon now we see that it has the name
armageddon
so
but this
root item one is called what still basic
sword
so we would think that we overwrite the
original
but it appears we don't and the reason
is because how we're calling this set
name
so basically i'm pretty sure this has to
do with how the function table works
because essentially when we're calling
get name
[Music]
here we're using whatever item it is
however we don't have it casted we don't
know what type it is we don't know if
it's
armor or not but essentially they do the
same thing they override the name and
you can see it's still get name
even after we move past this section or
let's see here
we look at this magic weapon
look at how everything's set check out
the item underscore we see that its name
there is basic sword even though it
shouldn't be but if we go look at this
one's item type its actual name
is armageddon and why is that well
because well this is also inheriting
from item this uh
magic decorators inheriting from item so
it also has that same function
along with items so the
functions in there twice if we call it
on the base one then we're getting the
base name
if we call it on the mat on on this
actual decorator then it's different so
this get name should not use this if we
wanted to get the name
from
this actual class so that's where it
gets a little confusing here so if we
call
this get name here it's going to
recursively call what would now be this
function and we don't exactly want to do
that we want to call
the base version of it
but let's give this a run and just see
what it does we'll put a stop point here
and let's see what this does now is this
going to be recursive or is it going to
call the root one
that's the question we want to
answer here here we go we call get name
let's go into it and it looks like it
recursively goes into the same one
that's not what we want
but the question is how do you get this
to all specifically what's being
inherited if you want rather than
whatever you're setting because well we
know how to set this one we know how to
call it like so but that doesn't seem to
get us the right name it doesn't give us
the one that we're actually setting here
well basically what we end up needing to
do is override this set name function
here but we don't make it equal zero so
you don't have to overwrite it if not
you just get the default one but in this
decorator we want to overwrite it we
don't want to overwrite it in the
concrete ones it's fine there but in
this one
we do
so let's go ahead and do that real quick
like so virtual
void set name
override
string
reference there new name here
and we will say
item
name equals
to
now it's going to complain about
something that we don't have access
basically so we have to call
that items set name
on this new name and let's see what
happens here now is this going to
recursively go into set name or is it
going to magically fix everything
let's take a look
and i already know the answer but this
will be interesting
we go into set name
it calls this root one and sets the root
name and now when we export these do we
get the correct name once it's magical
and the answer is yes we do
but what happened here we no longer got
a name out of this or yeah we did but it
was the wrong name
it actually changed weapon one for real
this time basically so i guess the point
here goes a little deeper let me uh
continue on through this
there we go and then we got the magic
version there but the basic version
should still say the basic version right
it shouldn't uh change its name when we
call magic
weapon said name now that's uh
we're kind of getting into another
theory loop here because now it's
a question of well if it's just a plain
old item does it like an unknown
unidentified item doesn't even have a
name yet and the answer is probably no
so we probably want to get rid of some
of these and do this a different way and
give it different root stuff
or just default its name to to unknown
and let other classes
handle the implementation of set name
entirely but the point is we don't want
to necessarily modify the name of the
base item if it's magical it kind of
gets a new name basically because this
this one down here is going to be its
root name um so maybe we want
another string for like a
custom name here or like you know like a
magic name
i guess it would just be magic name
let's stick with putting the underscore
here and in that case we would set
we would do something different with
this set name when we're in the magic
decorator basically we just call we just
go like this magic
name
tools name and so in this case now when
we call git name we need to decide well
this original one is going to call
whatever the item inside is but we might
just want it to be
magic
and in this
magic plus 2 whatever it is get item
type
this will be
a little different as well we could
customize it with its name if we want to
put the type in there we can
but i kind of feel like it'd be cool
cooler to say
i'll get rid of this magic we just have
a plus or a minus if it's magical
basically and then we have the modifier
and then we have the string but instead
of the string let's go
uh let's add something else here
we want its original name
item so this should get like basic sword
it'll say like a plus two basic sword
now armageddon the plus two a basic
sword another space here
and maybe we'll keep that item type
there at the end because we you know
ideally this would be in its own little
section you know like maybe have an icon
and it says armor weapon on it somewhere
so this is kind of what that's for but
getting a little odd at this point okay
let's say play on this um
got a broken thing what do we got here
just a syntax error it looks like yeah
there we go i think we're gonna go ahead
and just disable all the breakpoints and
run it and see what our output is and
see if we get what we expect and we do
basic sword is fine but now armageddon
is a plus two basic sword and we got uh
type there weapon and then the damage
was a separate c out there on our main
uh like that
but as you can see get name on weapon
just did basic sword
get name on the magic weapon no longer
tries to modify
the basic weapons name um so maybe
there's some special costs you want to
put in there for those situations which
i didn't really do but we worked around
it anyway we got its special name there
we got this modifier we got what it
originally was
and uh and that is a weapon
so
that's uh that's getting into the thick
of it with decorating in a dynamic
fashion see if you can figure out how to
do this statically if you want a good
challenge if you kind of understand this
and the way to expand this further which
you know would take a lot of over
explaining once again is basically make
other decorators and since this magic
decorator is also an item you could
magic a magic thing and just keep going
um for example we could go
um once again another magic decorator
and call
it
uh
like i don't know x2 magic weapon if it
got enchanted once again and we pass in
here this original magic weapon since
it's an item it is legal and we can do
that let's put another modifier two on
there but now we're gonna have to
consider that because we got a cascade
of things could potentially get pretty
wonky i don't know let's just do a final
display of this x21 this get damage is
oh
let's see here not virtual or anything
yeah we should be able to call well we
have to call this on a concrete weapon
so that's like maybe get base damage is
a better name for that we get the base
damage
whatever weapon it's coming from
so this isn't super intuitive to get the
damage i guess is the point um which is
sort of weird we should probably put a
function in these magic decorators to
handle that but it's going to take some
more dynamic casting and checking and
that might be a good thing to see if you
can figure out see if we can figure out
how to make it so that you call this
uh get damaged like if you want to get
the damage of the x2 weapon you should
be able to call get damage and i should
get it all properly
without needing a reference to the
original one right there
anyway that would be the further
extension and here we go we've got
a cascade effect going on you see it's a
plus two basic sword it's armageddon and
then it's got a new name again which we
didn't fill out
but it looks like it casted eventually
too unknown because our cast check and
this magic decorator
on the get
item type it's only looking for concrete
armor and concrete weapon it's not
looking for magic decorators too so
that's kind of a cascade we don't
necessarily want but it is possible just
because of the way that the magic
decorator is also an item and that's
essentially how you can start working up
adding um what am i trying to say here i
guess just cascading effects now we're
obviously constructing here what you
could do is you could put functions
within your decorators or within a
concrete one to allow
setting certain properties and identify
them that way which is kind of beyond
the scope of this would be another level
so i don't know maybe if we ever get to
designing an actual proper game i'll be
able to make examples and then show you
how it works in game but since this is a
wild undirected example we're going to
leave it at this and hopefully that
helps to make sense and you can see how
you can cascade stuff
another next step would be to use the
move operation on this stuff so that we
actually move it in kind of like that
web page auth we did in part one just
that would
that would do some different things as
well all right well as you can see
there's a lot you do with decorators and
if you've got that giant hierarchy
something like this might start working
better depending on how you're
organizing things that's basically the
entire point all right thanks for
watching i'll see you guys